i gained 200 blitz points this past week
i finally broke 1500 today and i hit
that on game number 666.
lucky number also creepy number
good job ryan well so many people
gaining 200 points
in oops
opponent berserk giving me time odds
let's play a staffer gambit back right i
went from 900 to 1400
in 10 days after time
[Music]
now i'm stuck between 1400 and 1500 for
a year
oh well congratulations hey it's
one of my favorite traps have a good
stream i gotta get back to work
but ill catch the vod later nice also
hello to myself
in the future oh future you on youtube
yeah hey eric what do you think about
that gambit
wait first things first let's let's
focus on on what's happening here
my opponent clearly did not watch my
previous video covering
the slime with blinding mates in rose
and daw
this is so beautiful
i i showed this exact line in my my
recent stafford video people redeeming
hello also
hello i'll catch up but hello to
everyone
and maybe goodbye to everyone
at least watching in the future this
game is about to end
okay eleven move win this is why you
should watch
and subscribe on youtube
be aware of this um the the main blunder
from white was bishop c4
and this is one of the reasons i love
the the stafford canvas so much
it's so easy for white to walk into this
someone actually tweeted me who tweeted
me twitter
i've been getting like so many tweets
recently
but someone tweeted me a game gif
yeah here we go to have an army of 12
million 1
400 internet players playing the
openings you
it's it's very uh very humbling
so someone tweeted me basically the
exact same game i just played
except they they played knight g5 which
is more
more torturous um
in the game that i just had the most
efficient mate
is knight f2 double check
it's actually so this is double check
and then this is double check
f3 in that position instead of bishop c4
and i have no idea how to
react to that yeah um
i think i covered this briefly
in my video but you have to be careful
about getting mated so don't take on f2
with the knight
the best move here is knight e5 and
black
uh black's doing very very well because
you defend the pawn you attack the queen
you attack the bishop
the only move really for white is queen
e2
and then you play queen h4 and um
this is computer approved and the main
threat
is bishop g4 where the f pawns pin so
there's no f3 the queen is tied down to
the bishop
um g3 looks g3 is actually most played
here
but it's very weakening just queen here
and this is still a threat
oh maybe very possibly
and depending what color i am so
yeah after queen h4 white's under
serious pressure
and the engine will say blacks black's
close to winning
so um yeah beware
be aware of the stafford that might go
on youtube
so youtube people hope you enjoy that
hope you learned something
and subscribe and i'll see you in the
future